In start ups there always seems to
be a tension between two paths.
Distribution, give it for free and
capture a big chunk of the market, or
earnings, also known as making money.
Charge for
your work but then you limit the
distribution to only paying customers.
>> However, if you think on
your business plan in advance,
there are many cases where
you can do both from
the beginning
>> A great strategy
will be to use the freemium model.
You allow your users to use
the service for free and
then convert the power users
to a paying customers.
Take for example a company
that does it very well, Wufoo.
The free version let's you try
the product and see the value in it.
They show you the benefits right there
on the first step of the registration.
They focus on the most
important benefits.
If you need to become a heavy user,
in their case more than 100 reply
per month, they ask for payment.
But at this point, you as the user
understand the work they did for
you, and it's valuable and
worth the price.